[Music]
there are still no leads as to the
identity of the the freaky folk hero
remains at large sir what did you see
last night I heard gunshot saw blood
handsome fell had his arm tore off like
wet bread and the creature run off into
the night he looks like a [__] up hot
dog that part was very shocking to me
[__] can we put that up anyone
that may have encountered the
Strang breaking news a group of armed
Street the nasty Lads they've taken
hostages at a misme lunch atorium
downtown let's go live We Are The Nasty
Lads we
angly who the [__] are
[Music]
you what the hell is that
the Toxic Avenger that's what the kids
are calling him I think it's
[Music]
swell